[Music] I
mean, if these tents are not replaced with tents and
people put them in, if there is a third earthquake, it is possible that the camp
will disappear completely, because it
is completely cracked and is completely uninhabitable
[Music] No one has the
ability to buy a tent and pay
$500 for the tent
[Music]
And it's not past eight o'clock. Parking. The
earthquake happened. Glory be to the Creator. I mean, the building was overturned. The dust was
buzzing. Tourists. Ambulances. And
God's destiny and what He willed. He did. We were parked. It was around eight o'clock sitting and God's eyes were upon us. I mean, we didn't feel anything but the
tremor that came as long as we were in our situation. Unless the
stone came on my pasture.
[Applause] That
means our needs.  It is clear to all people that our belongings are
under two
feet under the rubble, and we want, if
the place becomes empty, to shelter in it. This means what
happened and has happened. May God honor you and bless you
[Music]